well there's been so much going on in
the news over the past year and a half
that some of those basic questions
haven't been asked let alone answered
let's start with the most obvious
question of all why exactly did voters
elect Donald Trump president it wasn't
because they didn't know what they were
getting they knew it wasn't because
Vladimir Putin told them that's absurd
no Trump got elected because the people
in charge of the country were doing a
terrible job
politicians big business the media they
are all on the same side
they all got rich in America moved
backward the election was a referendum
on them a ruling class the result was a
throbbing middle finger wagging in their
face they don't understand that yet and
they don't care to learn so to help I
just wrote a book about how badly they
shafted the country it's called ship of
fools how a selfish ruling class is
bringing America to the brink of
revolution because it is the book is out
this fall it's available for pre-order
now we'll be talking about its themes
until then because that's what this show
is about anyway and has always been
about I hope you enjoy the book and we
hope you continue to enjoy the show
think about that book aside just for one
moment an election happens that nobody
predicted and nobody bothers to think
through why it happened that's the
country we're living in and that right
there is a referendum on the wisdom of
the people in charge they're not wise